henri sterdyniak économiste à
l'observatoire français des conjonctures
économiques membres du collectif des
économistes atterrés
bonsoir henri sterdyniak merci d'être
avec nous alors on l'a pris 1
en fin d'après-midi les entreprises as
you grow 15% du coup dès le 1er juin
plus en tout cas de prise en charge
complète à partir de cette date
votre réaction d'abord j'avais mis en
place un système qui était extrêmement
généreux puisque l'état prenait en
charge en totalité le salaire de
personnes qui restaient chez eux
ce système a très bien fonctionné
puisque la france n'a pas connu de
fortes eu jusqu'à présent de forte
poussée du chômage
comme on a pu le voir ou aux états unis
c'est un système qui naturellement doit
petit à petit être mis en extension
parce que faut que les gens retournent
au travail
la grande question c'est de savoir est
ce que on ne met pas en extension trop
tôt sachant qu' il reste encore beaucoup
d'entreprises de 2,2 cas où les salariés
ne peuvent pas venir travailler pour des
raisons de transport pour des raisons
d'enfants et de prison de garde
d'enfants et là c'est peut-être un peu
tôt vous pensez qu'on avait les moyens
en france vu l'ampleur de la dette
publique de prolonger cette mesure qui
coûte effectivement très très cher à
l'état
cette mesure coûte à peu près 24
milliards par mois
disons c'est partager 16 milliards à
l'état 1 8 milliard à l'unedic ce qui ce
qui va poser problème dans les années à
venir parce que l'unedic va avoir une
dette très importante
bon c'est une généralité dans l'ensemble
des pays
on accepte le gonflement de la de la
dette publique c'est une nécessité de la
situation actuelle un peu partout les
dettes publiques vont ou menthe et donc
s'il conséquences de la crise
autre question henri sterdyniak on
attend des annonces un douar philippe
l'a dit aujourd'hui pour jeudi
concernant les cafés restaurants les
hôtels c'est un pas très important
évidemment de l'économie de notre pays
qu'est ce qui est souhaitable selon vous
en termes de réouverture notamment nous
avons comme toujours un arbitrage à
faire entre d'un côté le souci de la
santé ce qui la santé des individus et
de l'autre le souci de l'économie ont il
faut voir que les français ont été très
frappé psychologiquement par la crise
que beaucoup envie de souffler mot
convient de prendre des vacances et tant
qu' il est assez légitime qu'on prenne
un petit risque est que relativement
rapidement on dise aux jambes 1 vous
pourrez partir en vacances à partir du
1er janvier
à partir du 1er juillet et donc on
comprend là la position du la position
du gouvernement
il faut que les gens maintiennent et les
gestes barrière mais pour sauver un
certain nombre de secteurs économiques
pour redonner un peu de goût d'ogives
aux français il faut obligatoirement
relâcher les mesures relativement
rapidement entre qu'ils ont au cours du
mois de juin
il ya beaucoup effectivement
d'inquiétudes sur cette crise certains
prédisent voilà de vraies catastrophes
vous en tant qu'économiste quelles sont
vos prévisions
si j'ose dire vous pensez que les
français vont recommencer à consommer
de manière importante et remonter un
petit peu relancer l'économie jusqu'à
présent d'après ce qu'on a pu voir en
particulier en chine la remontée est
très lente les les individus hopper
pendant très longtemps de retourner dans
les magasins ils ont peur des que ils
ont peur d'être comptable et et surtout
ils ont pas l' enthousiasme pour se
lancer dans des achats en particulier
dans des achats de l'us les gens vont
pas retourner dans les restaurants
si on leur dit que en fait ici ou dans
des bulles en plastique tout ça fait que
naturellement la reprise va prendre un
certain temps et donc il faut avoir un
discours un peu optimiste et dire aux
deux jambes
voilà pour sauver l'économie ben il faut
absolument que vous acceptiez de refaire
des des achats agressivement le
sentiment naturel des gens ces deux en
quelque sorte de ceux de rester chez eux
d'éviter les achats de faire des
économies et ça nous entraîne dans une
spirale très dangereuse et donc il faut
prendre sur soi et il faut absolument
repartir refaire des achats ce nom
l'économie ne repartira pas et c'est là
la difficulté la situation
il fut bien que on a été atteint si
logiquement il faut absolument retrouver
les chemins de du thé magasin sachant
que tendent dans deux trois mois va bien
sûr faudra se poser la question comment
on prend le tournoi écologique mais
aussi être des achats pendant quelques
mois pour relancer la machine
merci henri sterdyniak d'avoir été avec
moi en direct sur rtl france